uh one more on fauci because the the
thing with fauci is that the fact that
he is still now in September of 23 that
he is still now on television that he
hasn't been shamed into Oblivion that he
still shows up and that they don't mock
him relentlessly well they often do uh
is is just incredible here he is this is
uh two days ago I believe on CNN with
Michael Smerconish uh talking about mask
efficacy watch this I would hope that if
in fact we get to the point where the
volume of cases as such and
organizations like the CDC recommend CDC
doesn't mandate anything I mean
recommends that people wear masks I
would hope that they abide by the
recommendation and take into account the
risk to themselves
and to their families and again we're
not talking they're enforcing anybody to
do anything
totally understood there is a perception
out there by many how many I don't know
that they don't work and that the data
concludes that they didn't work in the
first go round respond to that on masks
yeah well that's not so I mean when
you're talking about at the population
level that the data are less strong than
knowing that if you look on a situation
as an individual protecting themselves
or protecting them from spreading it
there's no doubt that masks work
different studies give different
percentages of advantage of wearing it
but there's no doubt that the weight of
the studies and there have been many
studies indicate the benefit of wearing
masks
I'm going to refer to one of them you've
heard about it before I heard about it
from a number of radio callers Brett
Stevens in the times talked about
Cochrane put that on the screen the most
rigorous and comprehensive analysis of
scientific studies conducted on the
efficacy of masks for reducing the
spread of respiratory illness including
covid-19 was published last month its
conclusions said Tom Jefferson the
Oxford epidemiologist who is the lead
author were unambiguous there is just no
evidence that they masks make any
difference he told the journalist Mayan
demasi full stop but wait hold on what
about the n95 masks as opposed to the
lower quality surgical or cloth masks
makes no difference none of it he said
well what about the studies that
initially persuaded policy makers to
impose Mass mandates they were convinced
by non-randomized studies flawed
observational studies how do we get
beyond that finding of that particular
review
yeah but there are other studies Michael
that show at an individual level for
individual when you're talking about the
effect on the epidemic or the pandemic
as a whole the data are less strong but
when you talk about as an individual
basis of someone protecting themselves
or protecting themselves from spreading
it to others there's no doubt that there
are many studies that show that there is
an advantage when you took at the broad
population level like the Cochran study
the data are less firm with regard to
the effect on the overall pandemic but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about an individual's effect on
their own safety that's a bit different
than the broad population level
individual level for an individual
that's so interesting because you fauchi
were the guy pushing for lockdowns and
school closures which weren't at the
individual level right you weren't
saying oh you have covid
don't go to school today you were trying
to shut down the entire school oh you
have covered don't go to work today no
you were trying to shut down the entire
economy so even when he's confronted
with studies that say masks do jack